[Music]
foreign
just put the jacket on please I've been
diagnosed with multiple
I love you cancer does not change no no
no cancer changes everything the bells
were responsible for bringing social
issues to the four I think they felt it
was a real responsibility because they
had this platform that they could reach
all these people my father was willing
to take storylines to bring up how
horrible date rape was and if this has
happened to you for God's sake speak out
don't keep this secret to yourself not
only have we helped victims but girls
have made comments that it's helped
their families understand what they've
gone through the one time that I could
see my dad really visibly shaken was
during the scene when we had to do the
date rape
it was hard the next day
um you know I had visible bruises on
myself just because
we had to do it right
groundbreaking storylines have always
been a Hallmark of The Young and the
Restless from addiction to abortion I
think Ashley had the first abortion on
daytime television and that was
important just because it was something
that was very taboo
[Music]
I remember being shocked I was like wow
this is big I had a summer where I was
bulimic I had a summer where I was
addicted to diet pills and I overdosed I
had there was bullying
I got the chance to play you know
someone that had cancer that was
bottling cancer the biology was so super
positive
cancer I had so many people reach out to
me and say like your storyline just like
helped me get through my own cancer
diagnosis and my own chemotherapy
my character was diagnosed as bipolar
I've done things I've really acted out I
do think that that is a lot of why this
show is so popular and because it does
address reality there's not just the
romance and the drama
our recent storyline on The Young and
the Restless has been incredibly
important because they dealt with mental
health and depression and anxiety and
suicide attempts which is not something
that daytime touches on often it hurts
okay
when I wake up
I don't want to wake up anymore
it was quite profound
it's okay
I had to actually mentally prepare to
like look at my social media for a
couple weeks because it was like you
just didn't know what you were going to
see there were people fully like
reaching out for help in a lot of ways
and uh and that being able to have that
kind of impact is is quite amazing I
will say the reaction was so beyond
anything I ever could have imagined I
could get emotional about it was so like
you know moving and um
you just can't believe that you can go
to work and hopefully help people in
that
much of a way in that important of a way
um so yeah that was really special yeah
ynr has covered a lot over these 50
years and it's also been a home to some
notable alumni I didn't know what to
expect
hello Christine
yeah I'll do grunt work whatever yeah I
can run errands on my bike I think I was
13-14 as an actor and a soap opera you
you get I think you get like two takes
and you got to be out of there it was
just a good place to learn how to be
professional how does soap opera yeah
you get a lot of acting experience
my Roots Began with The Young and the
Restless
Bill Bell took a shot on a very green
actor from the Midwest you're gonna make
me spell it out for you still to this
day Wherever I Go people say hey Snapper
and I go wow 34 years I'm still learning
lines I mean they do 100 Pages a day it
just goes oh on and on and on
[Music]
my name is Shamar Moore and I play
Malcolm in Young and the Restless
poor stomach one two three the Soaps of
the land of beautiful people you know
and so it comes with the territory
they were looking for my character
looked at 368 guys or something like
that is what I was told and they saw my
picture in the magazine and said we like
his look if he can halfway act we got a
job for him
I love Shamar you know we got to play
that whole storyline where I did find
out that he was actually my dad and he's
great I mean such a great actor he's so
fun to work with
I did I did eight years of Young and
Restless God
it's good again this was the foundation
that set it up for me we have had so
many
celebrities on the show hey I'm ready
Katy Perry Enrique Iglesias Smokey
Robinson and Cheryl Underwood just to
name a few have all visited Genoa City
here I am on the Soaps how about that
[Music]
what they call the answer is absolutely
are you kidding me
I'm not pronounce you husband and wife
if you watch the show I've been for many
years after everybody and I don't think
nobody in the country Mr Heaven yeah
[Music]
oh man to have Thomas Hopkins who played
my mom on Family Matters here on the
show was incredible hello Divine hello
it's nice to meet you she's been
watching for a long time long time when
I found that out every chance I I got I
was telling the writers and producers
you guys got to figure out a way to have
her come on the show
the character they wrote for her is
someone that could pop in and out
anytime so you might see her down the
line
I'm completely out of my Lane are you
kidding me so this is like I'm gonna
tell you right now she's great but thank
you you had to audition I did
[Music]
oh my God I am so sorry look at this
mask what are you thinking oh I was so
nervous and I remember that she was a
big soap fan
when I first met her on The Housewives
and I thought it would be a fun thing to
gift her apart for her birthday
obvious that she had some chops we
always enjoy a good coma because we
don't have to do hair makeup and there's
no lines you just lie there looking
green and it's bad that everybody comes
and cries over you and you don't have to
do anything I've had a good comment on
sure we love a good dramatic scene but
there's another reason fans have been
coming back to The Young and the
Restless for 50 years the fashion
[Music]
here's what we do we take this you see
it and then we we just we cut it off the
Glam is so fun I mean I'd be lying if I
said it wasn't I managed to grab a purse
that you've been lusting after shut up
it's not that fun
I hate to burst everybody's balloon no
you know of course it's funding but when
you've been doing it a long time but
these sequins under the armpits they
burn so many of us I'm not even kidding
the actresses were like going we have
like the sequin burn what do you mean
you're having a hair emergency I'm sure
you look beautiful I think
some of us would prefer to come in here
and just do our scenes looking like how
we really look
the fans wouldn't like that
so what does it take to keep this cast
looking good we'll try 3 000 costumes a
year pulled together by a staff of nine
most things are altered for a perfect
fit and sometimes pieces are custom made
like purses belts and these handcrafted
masks that took a month to create okay
now we are in the ynr wardrobe
department and I'm bringing you to a
very exclusive spot Victoria's section
beautiful right right there are
literally hundreds and thousands of
blouses and skirts and sweaters and
shoes and I mean look it's like it's
like mountains and mountains of clothing
but this is where they keep all of my
stuff half of this stuff I've never worn
but I will wear it
this looks like something Jill might
wear actually oops
I think I broke it usually the Wardrobe
department will bring to the studio a
whole bunch of clothes that they have
pulled from the stores and then those
have to be tried on so I'll fit into
everything some things just don't fit
right yeah there may be an item that I
just I don't agree with or they don't so
after all those decisions are made we
know what I'm gonna wear
another perk of the Wardrobe Department
we do get to borrow the clothes when we
have other events to go to it's really
exciting if you have like a dinner after
work and you walk in everyone's like
whoa and I'm like well this took like
nine hours you know smoke and mirrors
here's the cool thing
is when the clothes are done they go out
to whatever archives
so some people not me
but some people have been known
too
not me not me but let's be honest this
is still a soap and sometimes less is
more it's my job you know guys that
honestly the dudes that are out here and
they like yeah I don't want to take my
shirt off they kind of bother me it's
like then go be a roofer I will tell any
story you need and if I need to be
mostly naked to do it
let's go
time
time was ever asked to sign an autograph
I signed someone's Bible
yeah that was weird
the last fan story that shocked me a
woman came around to my side and there
was a tattoo of me
my face
on her rump
well yes I do vaguely remember that
a couple of people with tattoos of Nikki
I'm honored
I've been in Istanbul where people are
yelling Victor
he went to the Wailing Wall and people
stopped wailing and looked and said
Victor I was there a few years ago I
going through far-flung places of the
world and people will say hi
with a smile on their face our fans are
the best and we all know that and we are
sitting here today because of the fans I
have experiences with all of these
people
that are remarkable whether I'm part of
going to their weddings or a shared loss
for all of us
when someone in this cast passes it is
the largest lesson and what a family
this is when you say goodbye to a cast
mate together it's time to celebrate all
that we loved about the great Catherine
Chancellor
Jeannie Cooper I love Jeannie Cooper
character she wants
her humor her heart yeah we were friends
off camera too Genie was the true
matriarch of the show every new actor
she took under her Wing she was generous
and funny she came to set and she was
just here to have a great time I'm going
to my dresser and get dressed
I have the honor of having Jeannie
Cooper's old dressing room where the
door was always open
you knew you could go in there so I
would and she would always give me
advice about men
we have a cardboard cutout of genie in
the hair and makeup room it just feels
like she's always there with us Jeannie
was on the show for 40 years before she
passed away in 2013. in 2019 the cast
faced another tough loss Kristoff St
John His official cause of death was
heart disease but honestly he may have
died from a broken heart after his son
Julian died by suicide in 2014.
Kristoff's final words that Julian had
come to take him for a walk
[Music]
Kristoff St John was just the sweetest
man
I I struggled to find a bigger loss in
my life than him he was uh
extraordinary he was
such a lovely lovely
human being
I'm so sorry
I was very close to him my husband too I
loved working with him he was a fabulous
actor well well look at you spreading
butter all over my pancakes from the
second he stepped on the stage he was
the most fun jovial professional but
lighthearted person here he was the
person who I had my screen test with to
get this role and I think that that was
why I got it was because with him it was
like I just felt like he really was my
dad I am always here for you you know
that like he really just loved people
yeah it was just a beautiful human being
a great laugh great laugh
he was just so Larger than Life that
his presence is still here and it will
never go away that's why it seems like
he's not gone 25 years ago
The Young and the Restless installed a
time capsule
for the show's silver anniversary I am
very excited for us to open it and see
what's inside
[Music]
I was here 25 years ago when it was put
in and I remember all of this like it
was yesterday Jeannie Cooper's personal
stationery
that's my mom right there Dr Olivia is
your mom yeah this is the speech that I
said 25 years ago I can't believe I put
that in there
like who am I oh everybody's gonna want
to see my speech yeah we love a good
flashback but who would have guessed 25
years later we'd be celebrating this
incredible Milestone five Decades of The
Young and the Restless and a lifetime of
Treasured Memories it's a remarkable job
how many people do any of you know who
have had a job for 34 years
and much less an actor
how do you bastard
Peter Bergman after extraordinaire I am
so grateful to this show
that it has afforded me
to be an actress
do what I love to do every day
but also be a wife be a mother have a
normal life I've been very very grateful
for that you've all shed
[Music]
great deal of my life
the good and the bad rage defenry
entertain millions of people all over
the world telling you this has been a
dream
as I can remember
that's what I want to do it was truly a
life-changing experience I remember
every moment of it I remember that I was
just hired for a few episodes never in
my wildest dreams
did I ever think that I would make it
past the first summer I'm still stunned
that I'm still doing this job I was
supposed to be on for three weeks that's
it like
dream here I've probably spent more time
with a lot of people here than I have
with my own family so I think it's a
camaraderie that
only soap actors share it's a very
unique experience and it bonds you it's
how we treat each other because we all
really do care about each other when you
do that
it doesn't get better than this this
show is remaining pertinent it's still
here we're still putting on great
entertainment and you know keeping it
going on against the odds 50 years as
long as you've got good characters
you're never going to run out of story
as long as you've got you're true to the
characters you'll always have story so
endless
romance and suspense I just pinched
myself that this is my job and that I
get to work with these amazing people
all year round you're grateful you're
you're proud of the work and there's not
a day that I take that for granted that
I get to come and
Right Where I Belong the title credits
see my face I'm still in awe I'm humbled
every day Bud it is an unbelievable
pleasure and honor a privilege it is
utterly unbelievable you know we get to
grow old and experience all the things
that our viewers experience in time we
lose loved ones we get married we get
divorced we have kids and these people
in real time with our viewers you don't
get that kind of relationship in any
other medium everyone will say my
grandmother started watching and then my
mother started watching and now I'm
starting to watch I melt every time
because it's it's a long time somebody
gave an hour of their day for 50 years
like that is a huge thank you even
though our beautiful creators are gone
now Bill and Lee Bell the characters are
holding true to themselves and they
started that he would be thrilled he
would be thrilled that that these Legacy
characters are still entertaining people
around the world
something just started out in his mind
in 1973 it's still bringing joy to
people that his his son and daughter are
here and celebrating 50 years or we were
so lucky to have a front row seat to the
best show on Earth your love and loyalty
to kindness and compassion
and most of all today to gratitude we're
so grateful for our success and that's
all due to the fans without the fans we
are nothing it's a very exciting
Milestone and I wish that bill and Lee
were here to see it the opportunity to
make a show that actually touches
people's lives helps someone through a
struggle makes them laugh even makes
them cry that is quite a legacy so from
the office of the great Victor Newman
here in Genoa City here's to another 50
years of The Young and the Restless I'm
very grateful to all of you who have
watched the show for as many years as
you have we have very loyal fans all
over the world about 50. it's
extraordinary
foreign